[Music]
G thank you so much for joining me
startup Nation United and been so
inspired by all these different
incredible initiatives and incredible
work that's being done and I know very
much about your work because we're
neighbors and the incredible operation
that you guys have built H right next
door to our office has been nothing
short of inspiring and remarkable first
of all thank you for the great impact
and for all the amazing energy and
inspiration that you're providing not
only me but but a lot of people in the
ecosystem before we get started into
that and dive into that tell me a little
bit about who you are and what do you do
in the
day-to-day first of all thank you for
having me um as I mentioned my name is
gal I'm a co-founder of a tech startup
and a
COO um our platform uh it's called boost
what we do is helping uh small medium
businesses uh to find a buyer and for
people to find uh business to buy so
helping people to buy and sell
businesses uh especially in the United
States um and this is what we do we
bring technology to m&a uh if this make
sense um and from the first day that I
heard about the were um a lot of people
talk with me what what we can do how we
can support so of course my CEO uh went
to you know the military service from
from day one is serving in um serve
military um so I found myself you know
managing the startup but still was
looking to volunteer and help as much as
I can with my employees with my Founders
friends um and we we I saw guy katsovich
you probably know him one of the
founders of of fusion uh VC here in
Israel um and he started this initiative
with uh with a lot of Founders and Angel
Investors and people working from
Hightech and we started the hech uh for
Israel and here called hamala hech um so
this is all right so Ju Just for context
even before we get into that tell me a
little bit about what what going what
went on for you on October 7th you know
from 6:30 a.m. what what transpired and
what was the sequence of events leading
up to the formation of ofal Orek for
Israel first of all you're in shock
right you started the started the day
you don't know exactly what happening um
but the first reaction I think I can
talk myself like personally but I also
my friends working highte and Founders
is we need to help and we like we need
to help other people um and this was the
first reaction and this is why all the
messages all the group a lot of
communities of Founders get together in
order to create this um organization
nonprofit organization of course um and
in 24 hours we build this operation so
like you building U you know early stage
startup but in the 24 hours uh with a
lot of Divisions for marketing and
operation logistic and data team
everything we could in order to make
this happen um and I think this is why
it happened that quickly because people
were uh knew each other a bit from you
know from from Hightech ecosystem but
also were so eager to help and support
um and had this like abilities to do a
lot of
things phenomenal phenomenal so tell me
a little bit about what what was the Gap
that you all have realized that needs
attention from a group group of
concerned citizens you know X IDF all of
us and um but but really you all stopped
what you were doing to come together and
do this so what was what was the
emerging Gap that you've observed in the
field that required the need for you to
come together and do this so the first
our first reaction how we can help was
to get in touch with one of the party
organizers and we got uh connected to
him uh he had a lot of data and
information about missing people course
from fun from contacting everything he
had in tickets and everything and we got
together with the data team we brought a
lot of people working from Tech in order
to find more information and compare it
in order to find a location of missing
people this was our first operation uh
Al together we found 300 missing spots
of wow people and 35 people found it
alive through this data team wow yeah
this is was like day one or two with
hard work of people in the organization
this paint me paint me the picture so if
I were to go in into the room where
happened you know what what would I see
going in there if I'm coming from the
outside looking in um it started as an
empty office and then around 50 people
in different rooms working on different
things but everything related of course
to finding the missing people um
everyone in their computers um and
getting all this information compare
them talk about them later on and then
send them to um so to the military and
um to officers in order to help in the
field so we were the operator inside of
you know hi the company basically so you
effectively became sort of an an
intelligence agency that helps the those
in the field I locate where the Miss I
mean what are you you're going on social
media you're making phone calls you're
contacting family I mean you're just
pretty much doing all of that at the
same time right yeah everything and
actually a lot of people from you know
uh intelligence unit came and help and
support for soldiers that weren't yet in
the work because remember it was the
first and second day and they got
together with ex like ex Commander
people with a lot of knowledge and they
just told it was what to do and then we
continue and this operation moved
forward not just from us we took all
this data and transfer it to the
government and they still supporing on
so it was
amazing phenomenal and and then you
evolved not just to work on this but
you've also I you you ended up filling
the entire office with logistical
equipment and supplies tell me a little
bit about that yeah the second thing we
we did in the same day actually was
gathering um a simple Google form of
request because we knew people want to
volunteer probably people will buy
things uh uh that they don't really know
if people needed so we did it the
opposite we build a request form and
just sent it out every everywhere so we
got in one day we got 200 units that
send request for equipment it was crazy
in one day and today we're able to
support that and we have exactly what
they need so we raise around 200k
dollars we aiming to raise 500k in order
to support soldiers and uh families and
you know civilians but we know exactly
what they need so there people in the
field that telling us I need codes I
need a medical equipment I need even
underwear you know simple basic things
that the military units need and we
bought that um we already bought I think
something like 10,000 of units of
equipment and sent it out yeah in a few
how do you talk you know share with me a
little bit about the operations behind
all of this because it sounds that you
know both managing team of dozens of
people getting the money buying the
equipment organizing it with the
requests matching the requests making
sure it gets to the requester how does
this whole thing how does this whole
operation function in a matter of
days um I think it's like something that
you it's like for me it's like an
opening a startup you know we have every
person um responsible for each team we I
we build like small teams that grow each
day I was responsible for example for
the marketing team so had a group of 100
volunteers helping me with the reach
getting you know our our name out there
getting this um the the donations and
stuff we had a team member that did just
the finance all you know everything that
connected to donations we had a team
member Logistics uh we have the person
connected to all volunteers together you
know like HR you can call that um and
this is how it this is how it works that
fast I think and quickly because we knew
that everyone needs to support and
without you know a missing like a
missing person it's not going to work we
need everyone in order to do this whole
operation you're right it's it's a
complicated operation and and you
mentioned that you really kind of
operated as a high-tech company doing
that so you were in a high-tech office
it was by high-tech people and you
operated it as a Hightech company what
what does that mean for
you
um fast especially as our early stage
startup
um and organized this is how what it
means uh to me every everyone know every
team member know exactly what they what
they're doing and they know they're
doing it so fast super quickly and no
time to waste and for me because I'm a
founder of early State start up it was
like obvious that this is how we need to
work we're in a war we need to help
people we don't have time to think a lot
you know and plan a lot so we just
started ongoing for example the first
day we didn't have this operation right
we didn't have the money donation yet so
we we said the marketing was bring
equipment to the offices because we
wanted success from day one we wanted to
shift equipment from day one it's
exactly what we did and then we continue
grow and you know buy uh why why was
that mo why was that decision important
bring the equipment to the office day
one we need a short success we need to
start with some success why why is that
important for the context of this
Mission he going to work you know um if
it was a regular like company mindset we
can take our time we can we can plan
ahead but we're in a war and everything
you know everything it's it's with the
time and people waiting first day 200
requests from units in the Army it's
crazy I saw I was I build the form I
know that I was amazed I like for for a
second I was like stopping my with my
computer and look at that and I was like
I can't believe 200 units submit to a
form that I just created you know how
how did it get to them how did you get
to 200 units to do that WhatsApp um Word
of Mouth
Facebook everything and the first days I
think of the war people like people knew
that and people start transfer it to
friends and family and people that they
know Instagram post um SS the first day
we had Instagram page that we opened so
an influencer that support us and show
show that show our message out there so
I think it could happen especially
because it was so early in the beginning
of the war and people really need the
equipment they still need by the way and
it's something that I want to share with
nothing nothing stopped yet people still
need the
equipment the rush of the beginning was
you know massive and people needed a lot
of equipment but we we still have you
know hundreds of units waiting for the
equipment this is why we put continue
fundraise um yeah so it was difficult
but definitely a lot of people needed
needed this so paint me a a picture just
on the on what's been done until now and
the impact and how many people are
involved in this you mentioned 10,000
units were of of supplies were purchased
I imagine this is a combination of the
different elements you mentioned before
from from underwear to Coates to to
different there well get share with me a
little bit about the the numbers of of
the impact you guys have had so far
including the team as well we started
with 50 you know initial team members
and we now between 400 and 500
volunteers uh people that come into the
office sometimes on a daily basis some
people working online with have people
that work from the state from Europe
from you know volunteering from
different areas um we also a Linkin is
helping that because you know the Tex in
a lot of people are in LinkedIn so they
see also build the LinkedIn page last
week people start to to realize we can
they can help through donations um we
have 50 companies Hightech companies as
well that promote us and their employees
helping you know helping us as well um
and this was also one of the first
things we got the the we got the support
of not just employees but also their
companies and it's also something
amazing to talk about because a company
can can say you know we're a business
we're not support but they actually
support and you can see their logos on a
website so they're really supportive
they're employees also some of them
wants to donate money um so 50 companies
and this number of force is is getting
higher we got to around 100 units in the
Army from different areas and we raised
as I mened 200k uh dollars for the
operation side and the logistics now go
through our in the few
days that's unbelievable and how do what
has been your experience yourself
throughout this time so not trivial to
put aside you know your day to-day work
and to jump into all of this and to
experience what you've experienced what
has been you know the the your
subjective experience since it's over
7th year and we the cont it's we about
18 we're 18 days after the start so
we're still just very fresh true um it
is feel feel long because you you I got
to know hundreds of people hundreds of
new people I got to know just from
building this operation that fast um my
my personal I can say um uh connection
to all it it's I put my you know the
startup uh um to be the second priority
and it was extremely difficult but I was
soldiers you know nine nine years ago I
also served next to Gaza in one of the
biggest you know operation toan I felt
like connected and I knew that I need to
do something as I felt there in the
field I needed to to do something that
people did to me years ago when they
brought me Supply or food when the
reaction to me and I remember that I
remember how arst to be a soldiers in
the field um so it was a must you know I
could I couldn't I couldn't not do it
but in the same time I will say it's
super it's super hard now I'm a acting
as a solo founder at the moment when I
you know do daily with my CEO that is in
in the field it's crazy it's like a
crazy Mad word that I like we laugh
about this but it's it's crazy I'm
managing a startup like that you know
especially early stage
one well it's it's really crazy but um
some you know investors and people
telling me that obviously people will be
more strong after Founders
entrepreneurs um people working you know
high-tech indied companies whatever like
everyone will be stronger from
everything that happened and I really
believe in that I see that on myself on
a day today so happy to see the next you
know the next level we all going to be
and and resilience you probably know how
much resilience we need need as Founders
um after this scenario and we're still
ongoing but um it's really it's really
something you know that you going
through I'm sure every startup founder
will have a different look I think in
everything in his life in his company
and looking forward to see the after you
know and to be with a different
mindset well G I think that really what
what you're describing here is just the
true
embodiment not only of what I really
and am gaining inspiration here so in in
the context of this this effort and the
United of of of coming together but but
also entrepreneurship itself in the
sense of you're an incredible
entrepreneur the operation that that you
and and your your entire team have built
together I know it was a huge team
effort and I saw so many people involved
in great leadership team katovich is a
fantastic friend as well and it's really
um it's really inspiring to see and and
I I I love the fact that you're also
sharing this publicly you realize that
it's not just about how many supplies
you send out it's also the way that you
do it it's the community you build
around it it's the fact that there's
you're you know you're you're treating
this as a startup mindsets you're taking
the problem you're quickly assessing it
getting small wins small victories
showing that it works s of getting the
product Market fit right I mean you're
releasing the form you see okay 200
supplies okay wait we we we don't know
how to logistically do that oh but we'll
get some supplies in the office just
bring it to the office we'll figure it
out oh we have we need to space okay we
have an office okay 50 people here it's
it's just amazing inspiring thank you so
much H continue making a positive impact
and thank you for inspiring me
personally and um best of luck thank you
thank you so
[Laughter]
much